all right phil we're gonna put 30
seconds on the clock and let's see how
many meals you can raise by making some
putts ready three two one go
that is incredible let's go let's go
that's incredible 10 seconds left 80 000
meals
feels ready for this
wow that's unbelievable
bill i know you made 15. it's decent not
that good but let's see if i can do a
little bit more
all right you ready
[Music]
oh you need a sword come on i mean was
that
do we even know
[Music]
either anybody know i don't know we'll
roll that back in editing it'll be 16
but bryson you're up
all right everybody phil nicholson made
15 putts in 30 seconds let's see if i
can do better
[Music]
oh who's that
nine
oh i suck
30 seconds 10 foot putts which will you
will not hit one i got a grand on it got
a rack this is golf brightness this is a
sport it's not even a sport it is a
sport you will not let's prove it right
now you will not hit one putt from ten
feet
[Applause]
[Applause]
this isn't a sport can i have my putter
okay
there it is
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
five six seven eight nine
[Music]